in our morning rounds we are looking at
how the pandemic is affecting breast
cancer detection
today is the first day of breast cancer
awareness month
one study shows that breast and cervical
cancer screenings dropped
94 in march in this country in june
breast cancer screenings were still 29
percent below
pre-covert levels our senior medical
correspondent that's dr tara narula
we love her introduces us to a woman who
knows firsthand
that early detection saves lives
what were your initial thoughts when you
were told that you had breast cancer
well i just said here we go it's my turn
now 63 year old norma atwood
has been giving mammograms for over two
decades
she delayed her own routine screening in
march because of the pandemic
and when she finally had her mammogram
in may she got the news
she never wants her patients to hear
were you surprised to learn that
something had developed there in the
year since you had your prior mammogram
yes um but i've seen it happen many
times and
once you were diagnosed you underwent a
lumpectomy
yes it's a great zero are you
cancer-free today
yes somebody says to you i'm concerned
about coming in because of covid
i'm concerned about having a mammogram
done what is your advice
we're safe we take all precautions i
will even clean it in front of the
patient
for them to be reassured she works at
sutter's alta bates summit medical
center in oakland california
where four to five thousand patients
have postponed mammograms because of
covid19
sutter health estimates that 20 to 25 of
those patients could have cancer
that's undiagnosed atwood's grateful
she's
not one of them and she's determined to
help increase screenings
using a mobile mammography van that will
soon visit
underserved communities throughout the
east bay area
does this make you uh more
able to tell other women that it's so
critically important that they get their
mammogram i have always told my patients
the importance because i've seen it
happen so many times so this was no
different
do not wait over a year come in every
year
dr tara nerula joins us now tara the
numbers are really kind of scary 285
000 breast cancer exams were missed
during the peak
months of covid why is it so important
that we go but we are afraid to go to
the doctor's office
yeah well those numbers are really
alarming gail because what we know is
that screening really
can affect our ability to pick up
cancers early
at a stage when we're able to treat them
and it can save lives
and there are estimates that all of
these women that have missed their
screenings may translate
in the years to come to increase deaths
and i think what the important message
is is that we're not talking about
missing your mammogram for someone who
is average risk without symptoms for one
or two months that's probably fine
what we're talking about is really
missing it for six months a year or two
years
and that we worry many women may do at
this point so
important to note the statistics one in
eight women will be affected by breast
cancer
second most common cancer after skin
cancer
second leading cause of cancer death in
women after lung cancer
and it's estimated about 40 000 women
will die this year from breast cancer
so very very important to get screened
early detection is so important
so how do you reassure women i've gotten
a couple of notices from doctors
including your office tara narula gail
come in and get your heart checked
where you know where they say listen you
need to come in and get this done
how do you reassure nervous patients
that it's okay to come into the doctor's
office
right well you just said it i mean one
thing is really is having that
conversation with patients and letting
them understand that there are certain
things that need to be a priority
and i think it needs to be a
conversation about what is the risk
versus benefit of coming in
and that really depends on your personal
history your family history your risk
factors and
what was the interval between now and
when your last screening was
also we try to really reassure people
that we've taken
in a lot of offices and clinics around
the country very massive steps towards
making sure that it is safe that we
screen patients ahead of time for kovid
that patients are spaced out that
they're social distancing that there's
masking so it is safe to come
into the office if you need to and now
may be a really good time before we see
a potential second surge before we get
to the peak of flu season and systems
become overwhelmed so pick up the phone
have that conversation with your
provider and see if you should come in
that's a really good point and what age
should women start getting mammograms i
hear
two different numbers yeah there is a
little bit of confusion out there
because there are different
guidelines in different organizations
saying different things but
in general most of the groups recommend
that women start being screened at age
40. the american cancer society says
that you can have a discussion with your
provider about starting at 40 and if
that's something a woman wants she can
certainly do that
they recommend starting at age 45 with
those annual mammograms
until 55 at which point a woman can then
decide every year or every other year
yeah i don't see a downside in getting a
mammogram ever
ever regardless of the age
yeah well it is a discussion certainly
you know the risks that are talked about
are really finding what we call sort of
false positives that can lead to
over-diagnosis and over-treatment but
certainly as i said
the bulk of the major societies and
groups really do feel that 40 is a good
starting point
all right tara narula always good to see
you can't wait till you can come back to
the table
in person me too good to see you thank
you